the Wind Blows the fishing boats home as
it has for the countless centuries
people have lived here
living by what nature provides
but not all is as it seems these are
malagase migrants they move from the
drought-ridden south in search of a
means to survive and their story is the
interface between climate change and
biodiversity loss
in our place we are suffering and there
is no food the kids are starving so
that's why we came here to below
it is too expensive to buy food but with
fishing we can find cheap even free food
in the local fish market amongst the
Myriad species hammerhead shark is
available for sale
it's a legal catch but it's a globally
threatened species
the arrival of the migrants is adding to
the pressures on fish stocks and Marine
biodiversity already stretched by
overfishing
[Music]
speed out to sea into a marine protected
area
but with fewer resources the no fish
zones are hard to Police from a double
threat
the first one is the migrants who are
coming in the dry season the second is
the big fishing boats who don't stay
outside the protected Zone and they cut
the Nets and damage the gear of the
smaller fishing boats
smoke rises in the distance that's more
biodiversity loss happening before our
eyes slash and burn deforestation
and soon we see the effects up close 10
years ago the Royal Forest here Elaine
tells me 900 square kilometers of Virgin
forest was destroyed by the migrants
fleeing the southern drought to grow
crops like peanuts and Maize the habitat
loss is devastating I've even I've seen
many limbers on the trees here the
dancing lemurs I've seen that many times
and they're coming over here they were
here in this five years ago yeah I
always talk to you to take them pictures
and they come around the red fronted
Brown lemurs or so they were here
there's no home for them now is there
yeah
for people fleeing the impacts of global
warming it's survival at all costs
and this is going to happen all over the
world as impacts like sea level rise
cause people to move further and further
Inland to escape Rising Seas putting
more and more pressure on environmental
resources
here in Madagascar slowing the
ecological decline is key but
fundamental to that is improving the
well-being of the average malagasy as a
climate they once knew changes beyond
recognition
Nick Clark Al Jazeera Bella Sumer
Madagascar